لم تحسم المعركه في اوكرانيا حتى لا
للطرفين قدرات تقابلها قدرات مضاده تمنع
كليهما من الحسد لكنه اوكرانيا ترفع الصوت
عاليا للمطالبه بما يزيد من الاسلحه
النوعيه من الارض
ترتكز المطالب الاوكرانيه بشكل اساسي الى
الدفاعات الجويه والصواريخ بعيده المدى
والاسلحه المضاده للدبابات
والمدرعات بانواعها والطائره السيئه تحاول
القوه الاوكرانيه سحب بساط الجو من روسيا
وتلك نقطه ضعف الرئيسيه بالنسبه للقوه
الاوكرانيه لكن الامر بحاجه الى منظومات
متناسقه وتنوع في المستويات لتناسب
الصواريخ المعاديه فمثلا لا يمكن استخدام
صاروخ من منظومه تصل تكلفته الى ثلاثه
ملايين دولار لاسقاط الطائره المسيره لا
تصل تكلفتها الى 20,000 دولار لذلك تستخدم
انظمه
لمواجهه الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه بس بالفرق
في السرعه لصالح صاروخ باتريوت بينما تسقط
الطائره المسيره بصواريخ قصيره المدى او
رشاشات ثقيله وهذا امر تعاني منه اوكرانيا
مع التفوق الروسي في الاجواء الاوكرانيه
تحتاج القوات الاوكرانيه كذلك الى صواريخ
بعيده المدى كانت منظمتها يمارس الامريكيه
قد دخلت على المعادله فاثبتت كفاءه عاليه
وحيدت الامداد اللوجستيه للروس في المناطق
الجنوبيه والشرقيه تلك الصواريخ التي
تخدمت وصل مداها الى 80 كم لكن من هذه
الصواريخ ما يصل مداه الى 160 او 300 كيلو
متر ما يعني يدا طول للقوه الاوكرانيه في
ضرب العمق الروسي وشبه جزر القمر اما في
العمليات البريه فان القوات الاوكرانيه
بحاجه لاسلحه مضاده للدبابات ومنها بشكل
اساسي صواريخ جافل وان لو وكذلك طائره
بيرقدار المسيره الترك
[موسيقى]
كلمه السر في افشال الهجوم الروسي البريه
على العاصمه كيا في الاس الاولى للحرب
الحصول عليهما الان يعني ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تتحضر لهجوم روسي اخر على
العاصمه من الشمال كما يعني فعاليه عاليه
في مواجهه التقدم البريه من الجهه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه في المعارك البريه لابد
من المدرعات الدفاعيه والهجوميه الدبابات
الثقيله والخفيفه وناقله الجن العود
الغربيه حتى الان تتحدث عن اعداد قليله من
هذه الدبابات ما يجعل فعاليتها في المعارك
محطات معادله مسيرات تلك معادله اثبتت
جدوا بالنسبه للروس فضربوا بها البنيه
التحتيه الاخرانيه اكثر من مره خصوصا
بالمسيرات الايرانيه الصنع لذلك تطالب
اوكرانيا الغرب بمثل هذه المسيرات
المتوفره لدى معظم الدول الغربيه اذا ما
حصلت عليها اوكرانيا يعني انها ستكون
قادره على استهداف نقاط التجمع للقوات
الروسيه على الارض وضرب العمق الروسيه اذا
ما وصلت قبلتها باضافه الى قدر على ضرب
رادارات العدو ومحطات اتصالاته لكن هذه
المسيارات ستبقى صيدا سهله الا اذا رفع
مستوى التكنولوجيا المزوده بها لتكون اكثر
دقه في الاصابه واكثر قدره على الهروب هذا
ما تحتاجه اوكرانيا لقلب المعادله القتال
فمع اقتراب الحرب من انهاء عامها الاول لم
يتمكن اي من الطرفين من حسن المعركه